je déclare le 75e festival de cannes
ouvert
[Musique]
courroye
on
il faut quand même essayer de faire la
part des choses
entre
entre les russes qui prennent des
risques encore une fois à ceux qui
veulent dénoncer ce qui se passe et puis
évidemment en affichant c'est la
position du festival un soutien absolu
est non négociable au peuple ukrainien
et ses représentants
[Musique]
où
couper c'est une comédie c'est une
grosse blague c'est le making-of d'un
tournage tout pourri avec des acteurs
avec des égos surdimensionnés une équipe
de techniciens pas très doué un
réalisateur complètement perdu et ça
raconte cette histoire là à ce tournage
et pourquoi ça tourne mal
ça l'aurait donc lui
[Musique]
festival
on se souvient de cette saison
de ce 64e festival de cannes
[Musique]